atlanta what's going on hi how are you
dr john
we are rocking and rolling how are you
i'm doing good thank you i'm a huge fan
of yours and i'm so thankful to be on
the show
hey thank you so much for calling and
thank you for being fan number four
this is pretty cool so what's up how can
i help
okay my question is how do i tell my
husband
i'm not okay with his drinking even if
he
if he's not aggressive or mean and
according to him bills are getting paid
so
everything seems okay but i'm not okay
with him
drinking what are you not okay with
not okay with him drinking yeah
i was a bad what are the things about
his drinking you're not okay with
he is a functional alcoholic and he
admits that
so he drinks a lot um it's
three to five times a week um
and i just i really tried every method i
tried being okay with it i really did
let me back up let me back up paint me a
picture of
the husband that you would like to see
versus the one you have
okay so i kind of have both of them
in one person okay so when he drinks
he comes home we might fight a little
bit
and he's like oh i just had a beer no
big deal
i'm just tired and he just lays he just
not very functional he just lays he
sleeps a lot
how many drinks a day does he have a day
if it's a weekend it's gonna be a few at
least
he can get drunk i don't know i haven't
he doesn't really drink in front of me
he hides it kind of because he knows i
don't like it
but to call somebody an alcoholic that
means they are drinking to excess
to the point that it impairs their life
and so
wha how much is he having four or five
six ten
drinks a day is he just grabbing a beer
after work every day like where is he
i think he's more like a beer uh
grabbing a beer after work
but then the weekend he gets drunk okay
almost every weekend and he says he
calls himself an alcoholic
okay sometimes it hasn't been a week
that
there hasn't been a week that he didn't
drink okay
so having a beer after work i would not
classify somebody as an alcoholic
that way um if they are
getting wasted three or four or five
times a week
they are they are unable to complete
normal life tasks if it's getting in the
way if it's spending money that you guys
don't have
if it is yeah that's that's that that's
spending money we don't have
okay barely making ends meet
that's uh that's saying uh i'm
working on it it's gonna get better
it's hiding beers for me it doesn't
he doesn't tell me how much he had
definitely does he have
you called about him and he's not on the
phone the only person i can talk about
is you okay
yes what is he hiding from
you i don't know atlanta do you like him
i do i love him you love him but
you love him yes i love a lot of people
i don't like him
do you like when he dreams i start i'm
starting to not like him
okay but you say he drinks every day
yeah
and i wonder if you've y'all have done a
dance long enough
to where you don't like him most days
and when he's not at work
and he's going to be around you all
weekend he knows one way to disappear
in broad daylight
this is this is tough this is hard
oh now listen i i in no way shape form
or fashion am i excusing
him getting drunk all the time yeah i'm
never gonna say that it's your fault
that he's an alcoholic
i you haven't convinced me that he is an
alcoholic
sounds like he drinks a lot but more
than that
um it sounds like
y'all are living two parallel lives
stuck in the same house
you're talking to me like people talk
about their annoying roommate because i
think it's at the point where i'm
i'm annoyed with it i really try to be
okay with like okay he just drinks
but his health is in jeopardy his liver
is failing
he has a really fatty liver
and every time he goes to that doctor
they keep talking to him about it
and it's it's so scary honestly i
sometimes i feel like i'm gonna wake up
and he's gonna be dead next to me and
that really scares me and i'm not okay
like okay so how do you how do you feel
how do you tell him that
okay i my guess my guess is
i'll cut to the chase here my guess is
that you were just more vulnerable with
me just now
i'm scared i'm gonna wake up and he's
gonna be dead
and he is big and he's got health
problems
and he smells sometimes but i love him
and i'm terrified he's gonna wake up
dead i feel like you were just more
vulnerable with me than you've been with
him in a long time
is that true it's true i tried telling
him but it kind of
brings a fight every time he just wants
me to be normal with this and
when i try to open up i can't
i honestly uh when he drinks i just
instantly close up it's like
i get in my bubble in my head yeah i'm
not okay with it
and then there are days when
everything's fine and
we talk and we laugh and i just fall in
love with him again i'm like this is
what i want
if he just didn't drink he would be
amazing he would be perfect
we have a three uh two-year-old and i
don't want her to grow in this
environment
honestly how old are you don't i'm 29.
how old is he
he's 35. 35. okay so here's a couple of
things that
you can do and at this point you're
gonna have to
you're quickly running up on what i
would call your or what moment
yes i'm already there okay so you're
there
if you want to have this um a
conversation you're gonna have to be
vulnerable
and you're gonna have to go first and
being vulnerable means you're gonna have
to open yourself
up to rejection and getting hurt there
is no other way around it you cannot
complain
whine manipulate punch
hide whatever your way to somebody's
heart
it is not real okay yeah that's true the
only way the only and i am a
six foot two 200 pound texas male okay
it pains me to say what i'm saying out
loud got it
yes the only way to truly be in
relationship with somebody is to be
vulnerable with them
is to say i'm scared about this
whatever this happens to be the economy
our house my job in your case i'm scared
you're gonna wake up dead
and it is perfect for a guy not perfect
but it's
it's common for a guy to roll over be
like i'm gonna be fine
marathon you'll be better off if i was
birth
and that's when you hold this beautiful
face
and say i'm scared you're going to die
yeah and some guys can't hear that i
couldn't hear that for a long long time
and so number one i'm gonna give you
like four or five things okay number one
never have this conversation when he's
been drinking can't hear it
right i tried it it doesn't work never
did okay
number number two know that
his feelings are part of the problem
he's covering something up
and it may be 35 years old maybe 30
years old it may be a combination of
things
it may be a whole host of traumas and
challenges and all kinds of things you
may not even know anything about
he may look at that little two-year-old
and just think
i remember how my dad was my mom was my
granddad was i'm never gonna live
whatever shame cycle he's in know that
feelings are part of the problem that's
what he's covering up
right so when you
go after him in his quote unquote
feelings with your feelings
know that you are bringing a gun to a
knife fight that's
that's the scary thing okay right um
try not to have blow ups if you feel a
fight coming on
back out and say it out loud i'm not
going to fight with you i love you and
i'm scared for you but i'm not going to
fight with you
not today okay
i think um
i think he was the first one he's the
sweetest person honestly
yeah he was the first one to say okay
i'm not gonna argue with you
i'm not gonna just um he was the first
one to say and when the fight is coming
he's the first one to not fight i want
to just be like okay
now but you know it's now that i'm
bothered by it
let me tell you you know yeah and here's
here's
here's what your addiction is to being
right
your addiction is to winning um
well he says i have problems too he
tells me well you have problems too
and i'm not going to give up on you but
you want to give up on me
because last night we had i said
i might leave honestly i'm at the point
where either
you go to rehab or i'm going to leave
and he doesn't want to hear
that so so that that response of oh
you're going to give up on me
you're bailing on me that's that's
that's a manipulative gaslighting
response okay
so don't fall for that all right and at
the same time
don't be addicted to being right don't
be addicted to having fights don't be
addicted to attacking
right be in this to solve this
relationship challenge
be in this to be vulnerable and to be
open and let this guy know he's loved
and let him know that you are going to
draw a line
and then you're going to decide what
that line is here's what i want you to
do i want you to write him a letter
that way he can see it and read it and
get really pissed off or
get really vulnerable really scared but
he can go back to it and go back to i
want you to write a letter
not one that's like you keep and you
keep and you keep not that kind of
letter lana
i want it to be a letter that says dear
sweetest sweetest husband i love you
we have a baby i want you to be around
for a long long time and i'm really
scared that you're not gonna be
you're not mean you're not unsafe you're
not abusive
but when you drink you disappear you
check out and i need you here
your daughter your son we all need you
here
and i'm worried about your health i'm
worried about your life
and i've got some things i got to work
on too because i'm addicted to being
right
and i'm addicted to the fight i'm
addicted to
trying to drag emotion out of you
kicking and screaming
and at some point y'all both have to
learn some new relationship tools
probably that neither have you learned
in your own
in the the relationships that were
modeled for you
and let him know that you're committed
to learning new ways to communicate
sounds like you got a great guy man
who's really struggling he's really
hiding
and it sounds like you're somebody who
is so passionate and loves him and loves
him and loves him
and you just want him to be loved and do
the right things
and then y'all just get in this toxic
dance and you're just burning a hole in
the carpet
pretty soon the house is going to burn
down so write him a letter tell me you
love him
don't put your or what statement in this
letter but i want you to go get with
somebody
i want you to go meet with a local
counselor in your area if you don't have
a local counselor when you go to
betterhelp.com
deloney and i want you to get online and
find a counselor who will meet with you
talk through some of your relationship
challenges
you learn some new skills so that you
can address him
and i want you to really think deeply
about you or what moment what comes next
because nagging and fighting and clawing
and scratching aren't going to solve
this
vulnerability is the way forward but
there has come a line
when you're in an abusive relationship
you're married to an addict
that you have to draw your wetland okay
i want you to get some professional help
with that
okay i'm so glad you called i can tell
you love him
and you want him so bad
he deserves to hear how much you love
him and how scared you are for his life